Avengers infinity war finally cease
released this month if you've been
following the MCU for the past 10 years
then you are no doubt highly
anticipating the film's release in it we
see the nose finally make his move and
attempt to attain the Infinity stones so
that he can annihilate half of the
universe and bring balance to the galaxy
arguably cinemas most ambitious film the
movie sees all characters from the MCU
teaming up to take down this threat and
it's a blast from start to finish as has
become a staple of the MCU there is a
post-credits scene that teases the next
film and throughout this video I will be
discussing its significance in comics
and what it could lead to in the future
obviously this video will contain heavy
spoilers and I highly recommend avoiding
it until you have seen the film with
that out of the way let's dive into my
Avengers infinity war ending explained
throughout the vengers infinity war
Thanos is on a quest to obtain the
Infinity stones combined these magical
orbs would make the possessor the most
powerful being in the universe and give
them access to unlimited power
Thanos wants the stones in order to
bring balance to the galaxy realizing
that resources are finite
he knows that overpopulation will cause
life to hit a critical mass and implode
upon itself something known as the
bubble effect theoretically the bubble
effect maintains that once things reach
a certain level of decadence they are
cursed upon similar to a bubble due to
greed and the necessities of life
Thanos merely wants to stop this from
happening by keeping the population
under control whilst understandable the
genocide that he plans is of course
unforgivable and this is what drives the
main conflict of the film upon achieving
his goal
Thanos states that he would finally be
able to rest and watch his son go down
in the film's final battle Thanos
manages to obtain all six Infinity
stones and therefore has complete
control over the galaxy snapping his
fingers he wipes out half of life across
the entire universe this kills a lot of
our heroes such as spider-man Drax
Falcon Black Panther star-lord and many
more after this task is complete we see
that the Infinity Gauntlet shatters and
breaks this is due to the fact that
Thanos has finally achieved his goal so
there is no longer a need to keep it in
possession Donelson dissipates to
another planet where he sits and watches
the Sun go down finally achieving his
goal what this means for the MCU going
forward is uncertain but he can bet that
the remaining heroes won't take it lying
down in the army post credits sequence
for the film we see Nick Fury discussing
Hawkeye and then watching as the world's
population is ravished by Thanos victory
in his last move he sent a distress
signal to Captain Marvel and utters
mother before vanishing but who is
Captain Marvel Captain Marvel is the
alter-ego of Carol Danvers who initially
possess superhuman strength endurance
stamina flight and physical durability
she has a limited
precognitive seventh sense and a
perfectly amalgamated human slash Kree
physiology that rendered her resistant
to most toxins and poisons as binary the
character could tap the energy of a
white hole allowing full control and
manipulation of stellar images and
therefore control over heat the
electromagnetic spectrum and gravity
light speed travel and the ability to
survive in the vacuum of space were also
possible although the link to the white
hole was eventually severed Danvers
retains her binary powers on a smaller
scale enabling her to both absorb energy
and projected into photonic for
she can also survive in space and while
she lacks a constant source of energy to
maintain the abilities at her previous
cosmic level she can temporarily assume
a binary form if empowered with a high
enough infusion of energy obviously at
this point in time with Doctor Strange
gone she is our last hope to finally
defeat Thanos and I can't wait to see
how this plays out in infinity war part
2 so there's definitely a lot to discuss
about infinity war and I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the film what did you
think of the final shot which heroes do
you think will be resurrected and which
do you think deserve to remain dead
comment below and let me know and if
you'd like to see me discuss the Marvel
films in further detail you can check
out my ranking of all 19 films from best
to worst at the end of this video thanks
very much for taking the time to watch
this take care peace
[Music]